[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el documental
un magazine de gran formato de la
redacción de france 24 soy armenia
fernández comenzamos desde que los
talibanes tomaron el poder en agosto han
trabajado para establecer un emirato
islámico en afganistán
después de 20 años de guerra las armas
se silenciaron pero la economía colapsó
y millones de afganos aún viven con
miedo muchos de ellos buscan huir del
país por el medio que sea posible los
periodistas de france 24 catering norris
trent y romeo lang loa hicieron una
inmersión en la tierra de los talibanes
desde kabul a capital hasta kandahar
pasando por los valles de la traca se
reunieron con ex combatientes que ahora
realizan misiones policiales en la
capital afgana o en kandahar con civiles
que relatan el costo de décadas de
guerra y activistas feministas que
luchan por preservar los derechos de las
mujeres aquí la historia
y
[Música]
no no no
frente a la oficina de pasaportes de
kabul hay un tropel
aquí a los talibanes no les gustan las
cámaras
cientos de afganos están llegando para
conseguir papeles y huir del país
esta no es una imagen muy gloriosa para
los islamistas gobernantes mantienen el
orden a su manera
a la mesa
la
mayoría
hoy a millones de ellos sólo les queda
una esperanza huir del país el país de
los talibanes
huyendo de la arbitrariedad la miseria y
el hambre
[Música]
un hombre
más
pero la administración talibán aún no
está al día
la mayoría se irá sin pasaporte
el emirato islámico de afganistán el
nuevo nombre del país está todavía en
sus inicios
pero
no
sólo
para entender por qué los
estadounidenses perdieron la guerra
basta con un viaje de dos horas desde
kabul
en la provincia de wardak bastión
talibán las bombas estadounidenses han
matado a muchos civiles
no es igual a muy bien
tula bueno me he dirigido
aquí están enterradas unas 60 víctimas
del conflicto en su mayoría civiles
entre ellos seis miembros de la misma
familia
a
había un sueldo de artistas
en 2018 dicen un bombardeo
estadounidense arrasó la casa de la
familia
digo cornada de chapa que dejáis don
shula mojar y valor para ti dt patrick
haggard nimia gira de boca
digo que la tocó loba
al norte de quito
grave limitaban a seguir la protesta
será el viaje participar el amor de gwen
revuelve de pulsar el equipo
[Música]
y
en mi libro uned
ya tu nueva gente un año
abrí la sala
tras 20 años de guerra los talibanes han
ganado muchos aquí los ven como
resistentes y no como terroristas
desfilan en los carros de policía del
gobierno depuesto y de vez en cuando
proporcionan autobuses escolares
[Aplausos]
de la nada nunca muestras para cristina
el tema que está parado
[Aplausos]
en el pueblo casi todo el mundo conoce a
alguien que murió por un ataque aérea
[Música]
los talibanes reclutaron imagen
de juana ante
una escuela para vivir por la realidad
sapo teresita
en verdad ya no hay combates ni ataques
con drones
no más atrocidades por parte de las
milicias y el ejército por primera vez
los aldeanos viven en paz
ahora salgan de afganistán está pensando
llamar a allí de rival para picar
bandera allí notas de tarija deshabitada
de angré sanitario futuro sano de tarija
el mandatario dio curva 92 de ipc de dos
manos a el monte
[Música]
tarde
desde las provincias los insurgentes
entraron en kabul la bandera nacional ha
desaparecido la bandera blanca de los
talibanes reina ahora
[Aplausos]
en 2001 tras los atentados del 11 de
septiembre
eeuu derrocó al régimen talibán que huyó
a la clandestinidad o al vecino pakistán
20 años después una nueva generación de
islamistas disfruta de los encantos de
kabul
atravesando nuestra fe
aldeanos que nunca habían visto la
capital
el americano
escépticos los kabulíes contienen la
respiración
el país está decaído empobrecido aislado
como nunca antes
están en el show del golden gate que son
[Música]
queremos poner la lavadora inventora
gustan o no le gustan en dibujo y amnet
el cometa familiar y facilite este día
que tarde la familia
un mito de diciembre de monedas para el
evento no mi poder y me demuestra bien
durante mucho tiempo que abul ha vivido
al ritmo de los ataques talibanes
a partir de ahora son ellos los que
vigilan
y ahora depende del punto de base
la mayoría de estos hombres sólo conocen
la guerra
cuando éste está
pero la dieta
bien
hagamos que por ancianos
su hermano dice comandaba a las tropas
durante la emboscada de espn en 2008 10
paracaidistas franceses murieron
durante el vuelo
de cigüenza mudar a esta edad
el francés y soldado
la salud una pintura una salud
de partida
es hora de cambiar de vehículo
sala mosaico con la foto la peor hora
al timón está el jefe de la policía
local en la parte de atrás su fiel
segundo al mando
asesinato tráfico secuestro kabul tiene
fama de ser una ciudad de mala muerte
y ya
jeje
frente a los talibanes y frente a la
cámara nadie critica a los nuevos jefes
de kabul
algunos incluso les dan una cálida
bienvenida
ataque
qué tal
fue la moda
policiales a la gráfica
esto llevó a lado
en este calabozo una docena de detenidos
malos vecinos malos pagadores pequeños
ladrones no hay abogados nada está muy
claro
hechos
este hombre supuestamente robó a un
transeúnte armado con esta araña
se te van a salir
al mate que si bien éstos
[Aplausos]
la toma es así está mi casa y alabó
abajo
armando naranjo hasta el órgano de adif
a seis meses vueling bruce huracanista y
casi me que en los pits androides de
ánimo de girón y actividad vanhoye
actual si regresaban de revisar a cabo
la conversión que adeudan antes ahora
voy a ser pescada animadora bastante
política directa hijos de rectora que
malamente salama luz se van
esta mujer permanecerá en el anonimato
porque teme por su vida
fue jueza antiterrorista en la base
estadounidense de bagram y envió a
prisión a cientos de talibanes
de los altercados o la medida
en bolsa muchacho fue modélica que
dirigía una luz de uno de los abandonos
el problema con versiones de jamón
morena hot mandan ojalá meterse entre
comentarios corazones ahora están
notando que un oso de este nivel que
gritó algo aburrido si todo le bastan
una todas las contratas
ahora la jueza se esconde los talibanes
dicen que perdonan a sus antiguos
enemigos pero varias fuentes les acusan
de ejecuciones arbitrarias
la casa era
comunista colegas ciudad
[Música]
a la que se quiera usted
guayanés
el sistema penal del emirato aún no se
ha puesto en marcha
william cohen
por el momento los tribunales islámicos
se ocupan de asuntos cotidianos peleas
deudas o problemas de vecindad
aquí el antiguo sistema judicial
destilado de lento y corrupto
y
más
o litigios se deciden en cuestión de
minutos en este día los denunciantes son
hombres
acogen con satisfacción a esta justicia
express que consideran eficaz
en cuanto a las mujeres que trabajaban
en estas oficinas y en todas las
administraciones del país los talibanes
las enviaron de vuelta a casa
vengan están hechas con morada en
tensores el planeta del timón de que
volver a hacer
próximo va a ser nuestros recuerdos de
observar las 1000 viviendas resultado el
10 no va a venir sanidad que cuando hay
un la casa ya está en que muta café le
en la faja y juana organista en una bola
de faltar red natural
[Música]
todos
yo
sólo voy a una meta mucho más con la
tara polo salta
modernas paderne se echaron a correr en
este dudan a perder más en que la
información mejora están vale que se
diga en esta jornada también con él para
agarrar el calderón que fue activo ya ha
sido el mismo mayor a éste en baracoa
para estar segura amina espera su
vehículo en el interior en kabul la
calle es de los hombres
cuanto más
[Música]
jalando para
el salón
[Música]
12000 buzek fila no siempre argumentó
codeme con el nuevo
salón de los buques
con el vigía en fila en el centro
académico del west moldear con fama de
giro tomado jamás doctora
[Música]
amina es una reportera de 24 años de
tolo news
un monumento del periodismo afgano
[Música]
tolo news ha sido a menudo objetivo de
los talibanes
o de la rama local del autodenominado
estado islámico
en 11 años 11 empleados de torneos han
muerto en atentados
su marido mientras
que san antonio mucho más barcelona y
hoy a cara que está parando el tema
mejor antídoto tercera búsqueda no no sé
si le adoptaron está marco este recurso
los talibanes han prohibido a las
mujeres manifestarse en la calle
la última vez amina fue interrogada y su
camarógrafo detenido durante tres horas
ha necesitado la vida
la última vez la mina fue interrogada y
su camarógrafo detenido durante tres
horas
desde este
lugar
pero yo seguiré
con filamentos escaladores
en medio de esta excursión atcore negro
stanhope cuando mora
ya hasta unos momentos después al final
de la calle
los talibanes intervienen
disparo de advertencia
la manifestación ha terminado
[Música]
en
siete meses
y
voy a aclarar
[Aplausos]
desde la llegada de los alemanes las
mujeres ya no van al trabajo en
restaurantes bar gimnasio
y se han cerrado las escuelas a las
niñas mayores de 12 años
pero sí sé
proclaman su angustia a los periodistas
y en las redes sociales
y
los guardias del parque están nerviosos
comparten la opinión de los
manifestantes pero no quieren tener
problemas con los talibanes
momentos después fueron dispersados de
nuevo por los talibanes
[Música]
salvadora a la familiaridad y erc son
miguel i want éticamente de que fuera un
auto había hombres de cavendish cabal de
tratar la falta control del
vino de un destino a
las playas
kandahar con 500 mil habitantes una
ciudad ultra conservadora uno de los
talibanes
pocas mujeres en las calles y siempre
con burka algunos de los ministros
talibanes así como su amigo proceden de
kandahar
darle a la navarra
manzanas con la salida no cierra filas a
un ademar afán
desde la llegada de los talibanes los
barberos han perdido clientes
[Música]
la visita al ministerio de información
es imprescindible
los talibanes han secuestrado a menudo a
periodistas extranjeros hoy son
bienvenidos
a mostrar
mucho más de sí de la marina baixa
jonathan racial
grande alternar igual operación
el estado talibán tiene una prioridad
obtener el reconocimiento internacional
sin demora
sangre de un grito de
morteros y deberán cesar a su habitual
esperanza afganistán que pongo bueno y
deseable
de formas más tablares y también mata
mmata de turistas pasan a ser habituales
también pensé
con esta acreditación se nos permite
viajar por la región de kandahar
visitamos la prisión de kandahar
el siniestro recuerdo más de mil
talibanes fueron retenidos aquí
[Música]
sometidos a los peores tratos fueron
liberados cuando la ciudad fue tomada el
director nos hace un recorrido
[Música]
los presos comunes también han sido
liberados algunos ya han regresado a sus
barrios
y
[Música]
qué
hasta ahora ninguna ong independiente ha
publicado un informe sobre las presiones
talibanes
según
[Música]
en afganistán el mayor productor mundial
de opio y heroína la drogadicción es una
plaga se calcula que casi el 10 por
ciento de la población es adicta a los
opiáceos aquí las crisis de abstinencia
se tratan a la manera antigua
tenía en lengua extranjera así como que
los alimentos que ya están aquí
brilla
muy rápidamente su versión cambia
ah
nos enfrentamos
cuanto más
por qué
ah
los talibanes persiguen a los
drogadictos por todo el país pero
durante años han financiado su yihad con
impuestos sobre el comercio de opio y
heroína
ahora
un
año
la provincia de kandahar es un centro de
tráfico
[Música]
esta mañana salimos escoltados por los
talibanes y guiados por ahmed un
respetable cultivador de amapolas
de acuerdo y si tengo por qué hacer nos
queda un límite
entre la pobreza y la sequía dice la
amapola es el único cultivo viable
estaré aquí
nueva zelanda cuando me la puerta
comunitaria común
a una hora de kandahar un mercado de
opio
los visitantes son escasos aquí
nuestras cuentas se despliegan ahmed
hace las presentaciones
[Música]
i
ah
yo si nos vamos por desgracia un mark
waid software y su camarita gana
camarada con los mantos paracas por un
año mandamos para casas
según ellos durante las negociaciones en
qatar los talibanes se comprometieron
con los estadounidenses a detener la
producción de opio
además de la tarea
de
tocar banda
en
la mañana
[Música]
pero la jara presente del flamenco
d
sí
no
las baje
[Música]
fue al oeste de kandahar al final de
esta pista donde el mulá omar puso las
primeras piedras del emirato talibán a
principios de la década de 1990
[Música]
y más concretamente en este pueblo
estamos en el corazón del mundo pastún
la etnia mayoritaria en afganistán el
núcleo duro de los talibanes
ahmad shah conocía bien al mulá omar
en
la
ciudad de
sangrar
tras la victoria contra los soviéticos
el mulá omar reunió a los señores de la
guerra que luchaban entre sí
e impuso una visión ultra rigurosa del
islam desde pakistán
detrás de estos muros la madrasa escuela
coránica donde reclutó a sus primeros
seguidores
de bruce está de más saber de lisboa
talibán de la tarde o madres tías huella
de este nivel de la madre 7 es
desarrollar deja la rendimiento del
rival al zarautz
en la madraza del mulá omar todavía hay
jóvenes talibanes
tenía 15 años cuando ingresó en la
institución
[Música]
como el de aquí
miles de niños afganos aprenden a leer y
recitar el corán en las gracias
los más dotados solo aprenden de memoria
en 8 meses según su profesor
dijo
el vasco
es decir por la sas de agua
[Música]
las madrasas son gratuitas la mayoría de
los alumnos proceden de familias pobres
que no pueden permitirse alimentarlos
[Música]
las madrasas de kandahar se consideran a
veces fábricas de terroristas suicidas
[Música]
pero cuidado con las generalizaciones
advierte el director se mantiene firme
en que el extremismo no forma parte del
plan de estudios de su escuela
del tapa de la gráfica de este
partido la atención alta de este plan
están todas en esta forma van hung de
nuevo al tratar y
el partido de europa no los hay llorente
años una mujer y niña regidor
malestar piensa en pakistán el
patrocinador de los talibanes pero esta
palabra es tabú
y sin embargo fue las madrasas
paquistaníes donde se incuba la
ideología talibán
mundo madre se pone vista en un buen
soporte está ahí
amalia y valsequillo
en esta madraza enseñanza sigue siendo
muy tradicional cuando son jóvenes las
niñas aprenden a bajar la cabeza la
mayoría no tendrá otra educación
[Música]
porque si se le agregan
así que se realizarán convirtiéndose en
buenas esposas
y
[Música]
por visitas nadaron manejo de escala en
hobbynews.es tan
benéfica me coloqué
buscando este reto de hacer que lo mejor
tiene [__] de tipo
la creación a verón me voy a ser
exportar a gestos de escena con
voy a tener que
defender la familia bajo techo
de negocio todo el archivo
[Música]
más tipo de robo me dijo débora giorgi
era natural que no el fondo
mejor trabajo y no se dejó de ver
monumentos
[Música]
sign up tiene 22 años y es estudiante
accede a una entrevista en un lugar
seguro que debe permanecer en secreto
desde la llegada de los talibanes dicen
las mujeres de kandahar tienen aún más
miedo que antes
[Música]
se notan agujeros asignaturas que
quiero ver hoy motivo las visiones
bonitos pero lesiones aseguró donde han
estado los jonas se lo ordene pero jonas
jonas hasta el doctor óscar dani doctor
o jonas jonas en ella pero si no tienes
que y voy a
sign up es soltera y vive en una familia
de 10 miembros es la única junto con su
hermana que aporta algo de dinero a la
casa
al mismo tiempo está estudiando
[Música]
pasadas
dos
semanas
es lo mejor
[Música]
se estudia en una universidad privada
para convertirse en matrona
en el afganistán talibán para las
mujeres que sueñan con estudiar la
elección se hace rápidamente
el
sentido
común
de
aceite
zeinab había iniciado una carrera
literaria
cambio su plan de estudios con la
llegada de los talibanes
además que resiste más
al final del curso los estudiantes se
apresuran a volver a casa antes de que
caiga la noche
después de los 12 años estas niñas ya no
podrán estudiar
así en esta escuela pública de kandahar
la carrera de medicina atrae más
vocaciones que nunca
i
bajo la presión internacional el
gobierno quiere dar un parte de
tranquilidad
quiere decirse
así que
está claro
que él no ven esa moral y de pitar
cuando bajan viernes
[Música]
pero el tiempo se agota y el emirato se
está quedando sin dinero
eeuu ha congelado los activos del estado
en el extranjero las arcas están vacías
mientras se avecina una terrible crisis
humanitaria
[Música]
colapso de la moneda explosión de
precios desempleo
para alimentarse y cuidarse los afganos
están vaciando sus cuentas para
contrarrestar estas retiradas masivas
los bancos están entregando el dinero en
efectivo poco a poco la espera dura
horas a veces días
[Música]
en la capital han surgido enormes
mercadillos miles de afganos acuden allí
para vender sus productos
el vice comerciante tiene tres hijos que
alimentar
[Música]
la tabla
colomar tomar
como estoy
pero pervaiz severa por 160 dólares
vende todo lo que le queda
las camas y la ropa de cama sus últimos
muebles los electrodomésticos e incluso
el juguete favorito de los niños
[Música]
el
carácter que les diría a mi luna serán
conocidos versos
es amor
de esquí matizó bailo tanto don omar
la que mayor y más fácil en la sede de
la ciudad de charlotte
para los dos
[Música]
hoy nueve de cada diez afganos no tienen
suficiente para comer
los desplazados internos que huyeron de
sus pueblos cuando llegaron los
talibanes y se agolpan en kabul son los
más perjudicados
según la 1 un millón de niños podrían
morir de hambre o frío este invierno
[Música]
en todo kabul hay enormes campamentos
para personas desplazadas este día amina
la joven reportera de todo lo unidos
investiga un fenómeno desgarrador
sin embargo para mí
cuando su hija de 13 años enfermó
gravemente
esta madre tuvo que tomar una terrible
decisión para comprar el tratamiento
vender a su hija de un año
más
quiénes son estas personas que compran a
los niños no se conocen los detalles
pero el fenómeno parece ir en aumento
cercana
como sea
y acá lo estará
olivos vivir en qué puesto muy directo
al mejorar haga bien los cambios el
cambio la tramitación bolsa motta la
función
el ministerio de los refugiados como
cada mañana hay una multitud jefes
tribales líderes de campamentos
desplazados todos esperan una audiencia
con el ministro
la semana
será la luz del sol música latina
advierte va a aprender con más calidad
cáliz haqqani el nuevo ministro para los
refugiados afganos es ante todo un
poderoso señor de la guerra e incluso
según washington un terrorista
internacional vinculado al qaeda por su
captura estados unidos ofrece 5 millones
de dólares
el ministro es un alto miembro de la red
haqqani en la línea dura de los
talibanes encargada de los atentados
suicidas
siento que la respuesta sea más lejos
austin y el campo
en los pasillos ministeriales del
emirato se aprende a tener paciencia
bueno
llevamos semanas pidiendo reunirnos con
los ministros sin éxito
[Música]
pero después de una larga espera
finalmente
todavía no hay entrevista
[Música]
porque tan ilustres clic aquí
las sanciones internacionales han
privado a afganistán de gran parte de la
ayuda humanitaria internacional
[Música]
esto
es arte
diferencia importante
un cambio
[Música]
lamentablemente no tendremos la
oportunidad de entrevistar al señor
haqqani
para hablar de los refugiados delega en
su viceministro primera pregunta cuántos
desplazados hay en afganistán
de
dejar sumarás words and arterial
escriban
produce las la caja algo presionado que
la habana están paraje el que vivía
según la onu son 35 millones casi cuatro
veces más razón de más insiste para no
politizar la ayuda humanitaria
deseas auditiva gasto
verzeri porque éramos nuestra hermandad
zarautz
warner
hembras tribu que usan dicha edad
crisis humanitaria fracaso del estado
aislamiento diplomático los talibanes
comienzan quizás su batalla más dura la
prueba de poder
[Música]
sus portavoces se muestran confiados a
menudo repiten el destino del joven
emirato islámico de afganistán está en
manos de dios
hasta aquí reporteros el documental
recuerde que para ver este programa y
los anteriores puede visitar nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom hasta la
próxima
[Música]